the russian invasion of ukraine is
entering a new phase
here's why eastern ukraine is key to
russia's military campaign and how
they're likely to attack
[Music]
the donbass area encompasses the region
of donetsk and luhansk essentially
running up the eastern side of ukraine
along a big chunk of the border with
russia
it has been at the heart of ukrainian
russian tensions for years
in 2014 russian-backed separatists took
control of large parts of the donbass
and have been at war with ukraine ever
since
the areas declared themselves separate
republics
just before the start of this latest
conflict russia formally and
unilaterally recognized the entirety of
the donbass region as being separate
from ukraine to
recognize the independence of donetsk
and lugansk people's republics
russian president vladimir putin then
declared contrary to fact that the
ukrainian government was undertaking a
genocide in the east
he started what he called a military
operation to stop this and achieve the
so-called de-nazification of ukraine
begin with the russians wanted to take
over the whole of ukraine they thought
they could do it within three days they
obviously couldn't then they thought
they could do it with a maneuver wall
whereby they took the cities
and moved in on kiev and surrounded it
they couldn't do that either
and so they're now in a third stage
which is where they're going for
something at least immediately far more
limited which is to consolidate their
hold in the southeast of the country in
the donbass and so territorially they're
now going for
about a sixth or a seventh of the amount
of territory they thought they would go
for to start with but this would be if
it succeeds
yet another bite into ukrainian
territory
the east of ukraine is home to large
communities of people who are ethnically
russian they speak russian
but for years many in the west have
accused putin of using this as an excuse
to increase russian influence over the
region
and it provided a reason to go to war
and take the land as his own
the fundamental mistake that putin and
his intelligence people and the military
made is assuming that just because
people in the donbass region were
russian speakers or even of russian
origin that they were not properly
ukrainian the fact is they're all
ukrainians and they deeply deeply resent
other than a pretty small minority being
invaded by a neighboring country
mariopol has been one of the worst
affected areas of the war
russian bombs and missiles have leveled
much of the city in an intense fight to
control it
geographically it's an important area
for russia to take with crimea in the
south under russian control since 2014
and the pro-russia separatists in the
donbass taking mariopol could create a
long stretch of land in the east
all under russian control
that's not the only reason why mariopol
is of strategic importance though it's
the major port in the sea of azov which
links into the black sea
and therefore handle a lot of material
so it's important because it's a port
and it's taken on a new strategic
significance because it's now the
southern anchor for this big
offensive the russians are beginning
and not least if mario paul somehow
somehow held out for very much longer
then it would it would be the david um
as it were refusing to be subdued by the
goliath of russian military power
[Music]
moscow has appointed a new general for
the ukraine operation
another signal that the war has entered
a new phase
general alexander dvornikov most
recently led russian forces in syria and
he was known for brutal tactics
targeting civilians
experts are calling the new focus of the
war the battle for donbass they will
undoubtedly be trying to create a more
maneuverous warfare in the southeast and
in one respect i think we'll see a lot
of tanks and armored vehicles trying to
move around quickly and ukrainians will
also be trying to move their heavy
equipment around their artillery but
also their anti-tank weapons to try to
slow down this this movement which the
russians are trying to create
it's thought that the russians want to
end this fight by the 9th of may russian
victory day marking the surrender of
nazi germany at the end of the second
world war it's an important date in
russia and it's marked by a large
military parade in
moscow this could mean that the conflict
is about to ramp up although how much
progress can actually be made in that
time bearing in mind the major losses
incurred by russia so far well that
remains to be seen
the ukraine resistance has been stronger
than most expected so far in this war
in the east forces are battle hardened
after years of fighting
but this new phase could push that to
the limit i think we will see bigger
movements of bigger units
moving around in this area once this
battle is uh really joined then i think
we'll see a really fierce battle at a
very high tempo
with a lot of attrition lots of losses
on both sides
cities in the region have encouraged
civilians to escape with humanitarian
corridors being set up but the death
toll is rising every day and this new
phase will only make that worse the
battle for donbass could be a key moment
in this war and one which neither side
can really afford to lose
you